[Music]
good morning everybody
first of all thank you very much for
letting to spend some of your time here
today talking about chatbots and
bigquery and data sources my name is
reza Rockne and I'm one of the solution
architects here at Google been here over
five years predominantly out of the UK
office but recently moved over to lovely
a sunny Singapore part of solution
architects role is to look at new use
cases new applications of our technology
work with customers very closely to
actually build out some you know Minimum
Viable Product pieces etc and then if we
find a good match that our next role is
to do things like blogs and solution
papers to scale that out one of the best
photos of my jobs is working with some
fantastic people like James thanks res
and thank you all for being here so yep
my name is James tremens I work at
Citigroup as part of the capital markets
effects trading team where I'm head of
data science there and today we're going
to talk to you a little bit about how
we've combined different Google
technologies to ideally enhance our
client experience for both internal
users of our products but as well as
external users as well and we'll be
building on technologies like dialog
flow bigquery and pub/sub this project
originated probably two years ago when
Reza and I were doing some work with
Thomson Reuters and if you're not
familiar with Thomson Reuters they're a
market data company among other things
and at Citi we were interested in
consuming some of that market data very
large amounts of it through bigquery so
that we could do different types of
mathematical analytic queries
visualizations and that sort of thing
and from there we decided what wouldn't
it be interesting if we could do some
more unusual types of ways to get at
that data and surface insights for our
users in a different way so the first
part of this talk is to click a working
great is I'm going to discuss the
business goals and also some of the
constraints within which we had to work
in order to achieve what we wanted to
and so I just thought I'd give you an
indication of the scale of the foreign
change in local markets businesses City
because that points to some of the
opportunities that we have in terms of
being able to reach lots of customers in
different countries but also some of the
challenges so we have thousands of
clients from corporate clients their
hedge funds to real money clients and we
deal with hundreds of different types of
assets we actually have trading desks
physically in 77 different countries but
obviously were one very large bank and
we deal in about 160 countries and
jurisdictions overall and we actually do
about four trillion u.s. dollar
transactions totally per day
so with that scale comes great
opportunity but it also brings some
challenges as our business has evolved
electronification is a phrase that we
use to describe the fact that much more
is happening now to electronic channels
through api's or even just through chat
less is happening through phone
conversations and so with that means we
have more data we collect more data than
ever before both in terms of the market
data that I alluded to earlier but also
trade data and with that if we want to
do computation on that we need more
powerful compute we need more different
types of compute we need more storage
so with electronification as the
backdrop
we also noticed that our users are
becoming more technologically literate
so you know a graduate from fifteen
years ago who came out of university or
ten years ago who may have been using
Facebook back then if he was an early
adopter she was an early adopter is now
the sort of person that's expecting more
from their technology in their
professional workplace as well what
they're comfortable with at home they
always expect at work and I think in
many industries professional technology
relationships take a longer time to
mature in terms of how the users
interact with their technology when
compared with their personal so we're
mindful of this and we want to make sure
that we can provide as good of an
experience in your professional working
engagement with City as you do with your
your private ones with your other
technology experiences like when you
work with Gmail now technology is used
to empower the existing teams that we
have and I think as a data scientist I'm
always very interested in
how we can use data and modern machine
learning algorithms to empower the
people and the staff to better serve our
clients so city itself produces a very
large amount of data and that's probably
one of our largest competitive
advantages and so we want to make sure
that we provide the right tooling to our
team so that they can expose interesting
insights to our clients when they need
to on demand at the click of a button or
in a very seamless way and we need to
better do that in a way that's gonna
scale to meet all of the different types
of customers that we have in all of the
different countries that we operate now
as I mentioned you know with all of the
different types of businesses that we
have we have to make sure that whatever
we build now is going to fit within our
existing technological infrastructure so
we have our own data as I mentioned we
have lots of existing technology and we
have our own data centers and our own
networks all of which already exists
today so there's no way that we can
build something that's entirely cloud
native that doesn't sit and interrupt
with exactly what we already have
working on premise so we need to make
sure that whatever we build is going to
work within this and that means that
we're going to have to think about the
architecture of the application and how
that's gonna fit with what we have and
we'll talk a little bit about that today
so it needs to integrate with existing
user interfaces we're talking about a
chat board or a conversational UI so we
have existing tools right that our own
staff and our clients are already
working with so we need to keep this in
mind it's not just about greenfield
projects all the time and leaving legacy
technical debt behind with you as well
so we've got to make sure we deal with
that and ultimately if we do choose to
go cloud native we need to make sure
that whatever we are building today
doesn't need to rewrite in the future so
just to frame it all together we're
interested in looking at conversational
user interfaces chat BOTS to address all
of the challenges that I just mentioned
our scale the amount of data that we
have in the way the technology within
finance is changing and the way clients
want to interact with us we're looking
at using data sets from Thomson Reuters
but also the data sets that we have
on-premise that are our own and we're
using technology like dialogue flow
which will demo you'll ater Google
bigquery and pub/sub to explore how we
can build this conversational UI and
make it work seamlessly so with that I'm
going to hand back to res and he's going
to talk to you a little bit about the
actual architecture and the application
that we thought yeah thanks James so
that last slide of James was interesting
it had quite a few components in there
and when we were planning out our
chatbot one thing that we you know
rapidly came to the conclusion of is
that no chatbot is an island so while a
chatbot you can build an experience just
purely as a chat board it's much more
powerful in the application well when we
apply it with other technologies and
other backends so being able to service
the things that the users wants
integrated seamlessly with both stuff in
the cloud and potentially on-premise and
for that what you need is a platform
which you know if you define a platform
it's a group of technologies that are
used to base other technologies and
applications on top of so what we needed
was a platform that could serve all of
our needs around both the machine
learning aspects around dialogue flow
itself around natural language
understanding etc but also you know
getting data from other sources whether
that's internal or within the cloud and
this is the current working platform
that we put together when working with
James on your right hand side we see
some of the systems where we're drawing
our information from so we have bigquery
as a store of data and our bigquery can
support both you know the internal
system data but also the external data
providers and we'll go through that in a
little bit more detail we wanted to make
sure that we could work with things like
spanner if we needed transactional
activity and pub/sub form that that
messaging but if you notice that
internal systems as well so whatever we
built had to work with both of these
paradigms also on the on your left hand
side for getting my left and right the
we have the user side of the house so
this is the converting what a user says
into actions we use dialogue flow for
that we used firebase to actually get
the information that's been retrieved to
the user if you notice we've had this we
built this sub hub service now what that
hub does is actually coordinate and
interact all of these communication
channels the reason we did that is
because we wanted easy drop in and out
of other components so for example we
use firebase but internally within city
they have other systems that
up there clients so it the system needed
to be able to deal with two types of
things very easily to with any any part
of this component architecture and
actually looking towards the future
intervals other things that we'd like to
add to the the other platform sure yes
so when will you think about what
dialogue flow is going to be doing for
us dialogue flow serves to sit between
the inquiries foremost from a user and
then what you actually want to serve is
a fulfillment request to the user and so
I'm interested in saying okay we have
all of this proprietary data we also
have a lot of proprietary algorithms
right we're a bank and so if I have a
user that's interested in asking quite a
challenging question that's going to
take a quant library that we've build
over 15 years to answer that's a very
much a custom crafted modeled approach
which we have on-premise working already
so we need to integrate the two but of
course as we move forward and as we're
already doing today we're interested in
using more modern machine learning
algorithms from open source libraries
whether that's actually boost or
scikit-learn or tensorflow whatever
we're going to service the request from
the client with whatever the inference
tool that we're going to use to to do
that it needs to work there as well so
you've kind of got custom completely
custom stuff on-premise a middle ground
with reusing open source technology and
then obviously we'd be silly not to
think forward to the future where we
might be using some of Google's hosted
model solutions so some of the existing
off-the-shelf managed solutions from a
machine learning perspective as well so
obviously there's a lot of technology
that we used in building out this
application containers bigquery's
spanner or firebase and we're not going
to have a chance to walk through all of
those things there's lots of great
sessions that have a lot of material on
that I'm only going to walk through two
components one is bigquery as our one of
our data store or our sources and the
other one is obviously dialogue flow
itself so just a little bit about
bigquery if you're not familiar already
it's Google's petabyte scale data
warehouse in the cloud like any data
warehouse it is an SI sequel it has
ability to build dashboards to run ad
hoc queries it also has a streaming API
which means you can actually absurd
streams of information into bigquery and
when you make a call
it's omits up-to-date data and that will
come in useful in a moment we show some
of the demos the other part of it is
fully managed and serviced in other
words the bank doesn't need to setup
anything to make use of it so one
component and part of the architecture
for bigquery which was particularly
helpful here is this idea of separation
of storage from processing now what that
means there's two benefits for yourself
so one in terms of processing if you're
not running a query then you're not
paying for any machines to be ready for
accepting that query but the other
benefit is around sharing of data so if
you think of a traditional database you
have the database software that you
install you attached Sandoz disk etc to
that then you load data into it now to
share data you either have to give
access to the database and I used to be
a DBA and that's not something I'd give
very easily or you need to build an
application layer or you need to do the
ftp dance which is never pretty
however with because of this separation
what you can have is data stored in a
project as long as the correct security
and ACLs have been done can be shared
with other projects so within an
internal you know very larger
organization or city they can if they're
uploading data they can again with the
right security and ACL levels share data
amongst themselves but also it allows
you to blend in data from external
sources very easily and a very good
example of this is work that we did with
Thomson Reuters with quite a few banks
so obviously Thomson Reuters have a huge
data set that is available through their
web service API but for pocs they also
work with us with providing that data on
to bigquery for the banks to consume and
that gives us access to 20 years of
historical tick data they also do a near
real-time so within seconds they can do
up sets to insert sorry int into our
database and again the benefits here is
that once you've been gone through the
right security and the access levels
there's nothing else for the bank to do
other than run queries what I'm going to
do is just do a quick demo of this we
can go over to the laptop please thank
you and that is a giant screen I'd
better not make any mistakes okay so
this is the new bigquery user interface
I'm not
gonna run through all of the
capabilities here I just want to
highlight one particular thing and that
is that we are currently in this project
effects project which is the one I've
used to do my development testing with
for James and within this project on the
left hand side we can see other projects
that are available because I've got
access to them or been authorized
against them so obviously there's the
the project that I'm in but further down
we can see this TR EMS project now this
is a project that Thomson Reuters owned
and they have given me access to data
sets within that project I'm going to
just quickly go down to one data set
which is a New York Stock Exchange
information here we have a table I'm
just going to select details so they
this table is five terabytes and 40
billion rows of information now for me
to run a query I'm going to run this
query on the top here against that data
so I'm running this query in my project
I haven't moved any data around and it's
working against the data that I've been
authorized against in Thomson Reuters
project and so that will take about 25
to 30 seconds that particular query
volume weighted average price you
wouldn't normally run it against all the
data I'm just doing that to show that we
can do it against 30 billion rows takes
about 25 to 27 seconds to complete so
there was no need for me to do my tap
dance routine which is very good for you
here we see 63 was the result I'm gonna
just show one other table I won't run a
query against it and that is in this
data set 2 1 3 which has effects
currency data and just the thing to
highlight from the details if I can get
my mouse and move this properly this
particular table has a streaming buffer
what that means is that Thomson Reuters
is currently pushing data into this
table and it is being updated in near
real-time within seconds so when a query
is run against that table we get live
update the information okay so with that
if we go back to the slides please so
that's one of the data sets that we're
going to be using thank you so now
towards dialogue flow so um and as I
said I've been here five years and it's
really great to see all the icons
popping in and how all these charts are
becoming so out of our cloud AI solution
set here we are going to be talking
about dialog flow and which allows us to
build a conversation or interface
against when users ask for information
we can extract information from the
intents that they have and one of the
nice things about dialog flow is that it
is you making more and more use of all
the ML capabilities have that we have in
built into the product itself so natural
language understanding so we have
sentiment analysis now within it we have
speech-to-text all of these components
are just coming out of the box with
dialogue flow in terms of the use cases
that we are going to talk about so the
one that we predominantly work with
James on was around the business to
employees so this is helping the traders
make decisions and we're looking in the
future to potentially towards doing
stuff around the customer that they're
customers in terms of dialogue flow
itself and we'll go through this in a
little bit more detail into a demo there
is an agent you can try and think of as
an agent as a sort of a NLU module it's
an encapsulation of entities intense and
context what an intent is is when a user
provides some information like says a
sentence the intent allows us to map
that sentence to actions that we're
going to be taking what entities do so
often when we want to take an action
against a sentence we need to extract
information and entities allows us to
extract those parameters a context gives
us where we are in the conversational
space so if a user for example is
currently asked for information about
euro dollar currencies and then the next
question is giving me news then we know
because they were talking about euro
dollar that that's what they intend us
to go and fetch and then we have the
fulfillment service which allows us to
make calls to all these other back-end
services and with that we're going to go
now to a demo of the client working
within the city environment
all right so just before I let it run
I'm gonna just orientate you to what
you're seeing here hopefully you can
read that so on the right hand side of
the screen or I should say the right
two-thirds of the screen is an existing
internal application within City we call
it the trader toolkit and for the
purposes of this demo I produced a
simple dashboard which comprises two
widgets one is a chart widget which is
in the top half and the other is a table
and that table contains interesting
economic macroeconomic events that are
relevant for the particular asset that's
being plotted on the left-hand side
you'll see that we have if you're
familiar with dialogue flow already an
hour of the box chat UI now obviously
you'd integrate this with your own chat
system if you're going to embed this
into your product so city has some of
its own technology which this would
embed too and of course anything that
offers an API this could work with so
I'm going to set the demo to play so we
recorded this approximately week and a
half ago I think when we do it the 16th
to the seventh and so the user on the
left is going to ask to draw a chart of
Eurodollar so once they did that
immediately in real time and we haven't
said anything up the client application
on the right hand side took that
information and was able to change the
chart and the top half of the screen and
the second bottom half of the screen
updated as well and so in order for that
to happen two things needed to take
place the idea of drawing a chart this
intent and the entities needed to be
extracted in this case euro dollar or
the euro dollar exchange rate you'll see
these circles on the chart which show
the relevant economic events and the
colors of the circles depict how
important they are and the number is
kind of the weight of how important that
event is and so the user can now
interactively say okay how about dollar
yen different currency pair and the
Japanese currency against the dollar and
so you'll notice that they didn't have
to say chart or show me something it's
just like you know very conversational
it's carried forward the context of the
fact that the users interested in
charting and it's obviously understood
that it's extracting a different entity
in this case dollar yen so the user can
now interact with the application
they can fiddle around they can explore
and do some analysis so it's getting
slightly more complex now we can do
other things so we can have other types
of intense so the user is now saying
okay please scatterplot Euro against Yan
and because the application again is
context where it knows that the user is
intending to plot euro dollar against
dollar yen so here's an interactive
scatter plot the x-axis being euro
dollar and the y axis being dollar yen
and some of this existing functionality
that we have within the application the
user can play around and instead of
plotting just the raw values they can
plot things like percentage rank and
they can change the look-back windows
over which that's calculated and so on
so we've got simple charting intents
we've got slightly more plotting intents
embedded into this application but we
can go further we can do more so the
next one I want to show you is this
concept of a back testing intent so the
users now going to say back test what do
they do
euro dollar after dollar yen is greater
than 110 so currency rates obviously
have values and the users interested in
knowing what happens to one currency
when a different currency goes above a
certain value and so in order for this
to happen we didn't just have to get the
and the intent and the the entities we
also had to have this condition and so
it's brought up this study of what
happens and you'll see at the top we
have this sort of time series and the
blue dots represent every time that
event occurred and in the middle chart
we have the average price path up to 24
hours later showing you and what's
happened to the euro dollar exchange
rate after dollar yen has gone greater
than 1/10 as you click in you get the
distribution of returns below it's kind
of like a nice study for the user to be
able to interact with so shifting gears
slightly moving away from just
controlling the user interface what
happens if we actually wanted to engage
with our customers so that they could
buy something work from us and we have a
lot of custom lingo and Finance which
you'll see some of it now so the users
asking to chart euro you're against the
dollar that's the standard when they say
that and then they're going to ask for a
price so the way in which a customer or
salesperson may choose to do that is
quite specific they say how wide in nine
million so they're interested in a price
that we'd be willing as a bank to buy to
them but so he'd sell to them and buy
back from them nine million euro dollar
and we only quote the last two digits of
the exchange rate we have these
so we're showing 49 on one side and 51
on the other and the users saying mine
that's lingo for bi they want to buy so
they're interested in picking one of
those prices they didn't tell us in
advance which one they want to buyer and
so they said mine and we've returned
with transaction complete and here's an
example transaction I'd be explaining to
them what they've done so following on
with this kind of idea of having to
train up on different lingo we have this
concept of cables so if you're not from
finance cable is the great British pound
against the dollar it's a specific
terminology just for that pair and so
they've asked to plot that and then
they're gonna instead of by this time
users gonna say okay make me three
million different way of asking for the
price instead of how wide they said make
me three million so we've given back
them a quote specifically for 3 million
cable and it's the same price because we
haven't integrated this with our pricing
API but that would be the next step and
then they said done left hand side and
that means that they're interested in
selling and they've done so so the chin
transaction is completed so just to kind
of summarize what's taking place here
we've controlled the UI to enable the
user to do some exploratory data
analysis look around at charts look at
the relevant economic events do some
back testing and then having done that
analysis they've decided that they
wanted to move into a transactional
business engagement with us and we've
trained dialogue flow on very customized
specific terminology and we'll talk a
little bit about how you do that in a
minute
over to res for another demo thank you
can you switch the laptop please thank
you so obviously I don't have access to
their internal system so when I'm
playing and trying to explore stuff for
James we have we built a sort of
parallel agent and I have no talent in
UI so one of my colleagues in Singapore
built this for us in principle it's the
same kind of thing
it has a graph of information we also
have some news information underneath
that we populate from Thomson Reuters
again the data that we've provided for
is this is 2015 that we have access to
from Thomson Reuters so what I'm going
to do is just show that this is fairly
similar to the application we had before
here we have sterling being shown so I'm
going to do show me a graph of euro
now I go back that should have changed
and let's see how dry my mouth is so you
find out show me a graph of pound
sterling there you go and show me news
on pound sterling okay so my mouth isn't
that dry so that actually changed
underneath as well sorry I didn't have
that highlighted that was just dialogue
flow the same intense were being used
we're now using the speech-to-text to
actually convert what I was saying into
text that was being represented on the
graph so in terms of dialogue flow
itself just to go through a few pieces
before we do another small demo around
some new features that have been added
to dialogue flow so this is the dialogue
flow user interface I'm currently in my
FX tester environment which is just a
play environment to work around with
intents for those you're not familiar
with dialogue flow we have the idea of
intents to actually convert text into
actions and entities what I usually
start with is entities in this case the
entities that we have available are
things that are put in including
currency now the currency entity dialog
flow does have a system built entity
called currency that would normally
suffice for any currency activity
however as James demonstrated there's a
lot of domain-specific language that we
use here and therefore I built my own
currency entity so I can overload it
with the domain-specific language that
we need for example if we go to
Australian Dollar
so by doing that I brought up the entity
Australian dollar this is the symbol and
these are the synonyms that are
associated with it at the end we have
Aussie as a you know one of the
domain-specific languages GPP so I'm
going to add one to this so this is
great British pounds and where I grew up
in north oh we don't actually refer to
pounds as pounds down where I work it
squids mate like to to power to quid for
a pint
showing my age it's been a long time
since our two quid for a pint so for
that I'm going to put quid and
essentially that's all I have to do to
actually teach it that quid equates to
pound sterling now when I go to do an
intent so we have various intents I'm
just going to show one of the intents
which is the graph intent which you've
seen quite a few times in the demo now
this graph intake takes a series of
phrases I'm gonna put one in now show me
a graph of quid versus dollar so I just
added quid as a synonym for that entity
what the dialogue flow does very nicely
for me is when I type that sentence in
it's already figured out that some of
the values that are put in our
currencies it's already highlighted
those for me and this is step one of
getting the extracting the parameters
that we need from this intent so if I
scroll down we can actually see the
actions and parameters here I've defined
the input graph action this is called my
code at the back end to actually invoke
that handler we also have some
parameters so for example the currency
parameter if you notice on this side
we've ticked this box under required so
if a user says show me a graph and they
don't provide a currency to me I don't
know what to draw so we're gonna prompt
them to give us the currency and that's
all inbuilt
into dialogue flow if I click on the
prompts so these are a couple of the
prompts that will be provided to the
user as we get them to give us the
currencies that we're interested in if
you notice we've added more than one
prompt this is like good UI design for
conversations to give make the user feel
a little bit more comfortable using the
chat bot if you give different sentences
for for the same questions outside of
this piece I'm going to just show a new
piece of functionality that has been
added to dialogue flow so I'm gonna go
to one of my user environment so effects
this is where we've actually got things
wired up and one of the things I find
particularly useful when working and
developing on here is the test UI that
you can use on the right-hand side so
here if I do
meaning a graph of y n versus dollar so
what this is doing is we can see there a
response that was given but much more
interestingly it gives us information
about what dialogues are extracted from
that sentence so I can see the action is
correct input graph I can see that the
parameter is currency and it's picked
out yen US dollar we have some extra
information which is not part of the
demo today also particularly useful is
diagnostic info so here we actually see
all the raw non responses that it is
sending to the back-end services and
this is super useful when you're doing
debug and testing just take the JSON
from there put it into a message and
then call your back-end web service so
the thing I'm going to show you now is a
little bit of a different flow from the
one that we saw with James so I've got a
currency now I'm gonna say quote me
two million my one is not as integrated
as James is I just say you know here's a
quote for 2 million xx YY if you notice
however there is a sentiment score
attached to it this has been built into
dialogue flow he was just recently
announced and it's this provides a
negative or positive sentiment to the
statement given now that statement that
I asked give me a quote didn't have any
sentiment let's say I was not happy with
that price and I'm British so I'm not
gonna swear at the system so we're gonna
say that's a terrible she I had that
there terrible awful price which is as
strong as I like to get in English here
we can actually see that the response
was oh please don't get mad now
obviously city would put a far more
professional response to that response
to that thing but well the reason it
said that is if I scroll down we have a
sentiment score of 0.9 negative now if I
go to some of my code to show how we
implemented this what we do is that
intent the handler for that intent looks
at the sentiment score for that sentence
if it goes over a threshold and you'll
notice that the thresholds quite low
I've deliberately said that it's going
to fire a different response to the user
instead of sorry we couldn't help you oh
please don't get mad
now the other thing that it does is it
logs to pub/sub which is our global
publish and subscribe API the message
with the negative sentiment and what
this allows us to do is to have systems
that can react to if a customer for
example is getting angry at us now the
sentiment score I showed you was for
that sentence however you can have an
overall sentiment score for the whole
conversation and this starts getting
very interesting in kind of things that
we can now do with the chat war the
other thing of integration that we built
was all of the intents I logged to
bigquery now the the results I'm just
dumping as raw JSON I use bigquery can
extract JSON information so this every
intent everything that's being done is
being logged if I run the query it
actually will show just what's on at the
bottom anyway but here we have the
different intents a confidence score in
what you know what we how confident we
were that was the intent that user had
and the sentiment score that was
associated with it now the reason this
is interesting is if we have a mechanism
for pub/sub to notify us something's
going wrong and we have the history of
the conversation we can write yes I mean
you can imagine if you're building this
for your own teams as I was thinking
about it it's City you know if you're
automatically serving requests from from
customers in our case it's both internal
users an external especially in the case
of external customers you want to be
thinking about okay well automatically
serving them but what happens if
something goes wrong and it might not
even have gone wrong perhaps just the
customers dissatisfied with something
when they came to you even before the
conversation and so you may choose to
actually have something published on to
pub/sub obviously that's real-time and
you can surface an alert to a user and
also a city employee in my case you can
actually Benfield that request manually
and slot in back into the chat and take
control and by publishing all of the
previous requests through the dialogue
flow interface whether that's your own
or something else into bigquery you
obviously have the history so although
we didn't build it for the demo you can
imagine that you've been alerted you
have all the the history of what's come
before the user can read up
understand the chat and start getting
involved in the conversation very
quickly so that's obviously quite an
important I would say prerequisite as
you start getting into beyond
traditional just fa Q's and you start
doing something a little more involved
this would be something that's quite
nice to happen and now possible thank
you can we go back to the slides please
fantastic I mean here we go so in terms
of the architecture patterns there are
two types there's standard deployment so
there's a lot of are things that you can
do just without other box integrations
with dialog flow that's both in the
front and and the backend on the we
using firebase functions we in our
example we use this very decoupled
deployment because of the complex
environment it that we are in and some
hybrid requirements so just to cover the
standard architecture the out-of-the-box
integrations couple of clicks and you
get things integrated it takes care of
all the things love like when a user
makes a call to the car to the front end
the queries get sent on to dialogue flow
for you you have things like you can
write simple cloud functions to deal
with the fulfillment side of things in
terms of our architecture we start if we
dive into what that actually means that
flow let's start picking this a little
bit apart so first of all the
fulfillment side of the house this is a
web book call so now if you want to
decouple that you can just stand up a
restful web service and absorb these
calls and give the response wherever you
choose to stand up your web service on
the other side of the house although we
didn't show it in the in the demo we
were using standard client it will be
important for the client
to be outside of the standard
integrations because for example we
would want the authentication
authorization for the client to be done
within city using cities mechanisms and
this means we end up with a topology
where we are going to have the the
client be essentially something that the
user builds and proxies to dialogue flow
so this is going back to our complex
environment document so here we have
that flow right so we have a user that
is an application that can use
authentication and authorization from
within the
environment that exists within city it
can then communicate through the hub
service through to all of these other
systems this is the flowchart of how
this would work if you imagine the
client is now a piece of code that's
sitting in a container at City the user
logs in they're going to do
authentication authorization with the
hub and the hub the code in the hub we
put into a container which meant it was
easily portable between our environments
the authorization once done the hub the
user can then start putting in requests
and that request is sent to the hub the
hub then takes that requests piggybacks
it onto another HTTP call over to
dialogue flow we get the response from
dialogue flow the hub can respond with
we're going to be creating the graph for
you if you imagine a trader is typing on
one screen they've got and I've been
into those rooms they got like tons of
screens it's really cool then in the
meantime the hub will also then do
things like make calls to bigquery to
extract the TIC data that was available
from Thomson Reuters
it will then once it receives that data
we send that information on to firebase
to allow the client to be updated so
that's when I was calling into dialogue
flow and you saw the graph being updated
that's what we were using to achieve
that so lessons learned yeah so I think
when you're thinking about using
something like dialog flow yourself I
mean the architecture that we've come up
with was something that I asked Fez to
help us with because we have quite a lot
down Network we have a lot of existing
constraints and rules that we have to
follow and so the hub architecture
really enabled us to work within those
those requirements where as
out-of-the-box dialogue flow gives you a
lot of this functionality if you're
going to be cloud native already or it's
a completely greenfield project there's
a lot you don't have to build so the hub
gives us that flexibility to take
something that we already have and move
towards something that's going to look
like production whereas you know if you
were just starting this from scratch you
would be able to do this more simply so
you kind of have the best of both worlds
when we started this in my mind you know
I kind of had the idea of what
conversations I wanted to
you encode into the dialogue flow
framework I had the lingo I knew the way
this was gonna work so we kind of jumped
in and I'm you know there's me talking
with rares and what we're going through
this and we're kind of getting excited
with how quickly and easily were able to
build some of this stuff but of course
I'd recommend like with any like
architectural design process or even
like your actual software implementation
process you know you actually do sit
down kind of with a pen and paper and
work out what you want to do first
rather than just jump in because you
know you need to make sure that you make
some assumptions that are the correct
ones at the beginning because otherwise
you're gonna end up I'm picking some
other stuff you've done later so are
your conversations correct for dialogue
flow in the first place okay
let's say they are you want to make sure
you know who the target audience is for
your chat book like any product and then
you want to work out for that target
audience what are the number one things
that we're spending time doing now that
we don't want to do or that we can do a
better job of doing by automating so
what are your key use cases and then you
need a persona right so in finance you
know generally speaking people are doing
a lot of work every day it's very
transactional it's quick it's fast
there's not much small talk really and
so you want this persona to be quite you
know efficient so that you can move on
then do the next thing that you need to
do so then you want to like sample or
you want to design things out you want
to test and that's the green the green
section here so spending more time doing
that at the beginning is going to help
you a lot later on down the line and
actually one thing from that previous
slide that I found particularly
interesting is it's very easy when
you're building out the conversation and
the intents to assume that other people
will ask it in the same kind of way
being from London and working with a lot
of folks in the US etc I know that to be
very not true now and it's very useful
to get a get it get some intense up and
running and then get colleagues and
actually say colleagues from different
countries if you can to actually try it
out
it's amazing the different kind of
variations that you get and one thing we
didn't show you was how easy it is with
the training with dialogue flow so you
get one of these sessions like you know
it's almost like a jam session right you
sit down and everyone tries to fool the
system you find different ways of
actually asking the questions and then
use that to train
and when you're doing the training make
sure that part of the training hasn't
exposed a different branch of the
conversation that you need to build in
right so it's very easy to start trying
to overload a single branch of the
conversation and rather than saying okay
actually the intent has now changed we
should create a separate intent to cover
that kind of flow the other one from
that first one is the tail latency so
what you'll find is that you'll very
quickly get a the chap were up and
running Lee in terms of the standard
flow of the conversation spend just as
much time on the the bits of the
conversation that might be broken right
so if the user goes down the wrong path
the contexts get incorrectly set up
spend just as much time there because a
couple of negative experiences from a
user and then they're gonna be reluctant
to use the chat board again just on the
training I think one thing I should add
is when I started doing this at first
you like a cake-like chart me Eurodollar
show me this plot that and you kind of
like showing a bunch of examples and
you're thinking I could just write this
myself with regular expressions like
what's the big deal and that that was
how I came to this and I was like hmm
but what you quickly realize is through
the work flow that dialogue flow gives
you you can quickly tag like okay this
is the intent this is the the entities
but you've given it like maybe half a
dozen or whatever three four five and
someone then uses the tool in a way
which you hadn't trained it on and
that's when you start like ah that was
my aha moment when I was like oh
actually it's gonna understand this
thing that I didn't train it on and
subtly and I think quite importantly if
you're into language like understanding
that you know something plot me whatever
that might be and then the the entities
you know you can also in a different way
right you could ask that like you're a
daughter show me a chart of that and
dialogue flows gets robust to these
types of things as long as you've given
it you know a sensible amount of seeded
information and that that was one of the
key things that I really liked about the
tool that at first I didn't quite get
and thanks Jason
and the other piece when you're drawing
out these conversations you know draw
out some flowcharts using the tools of
dialogue flow has in terms of like slot
filling which was where we asked for
currencies when one wasn't given now
context which we didn't show you allows
you to store the context of a
conversation as you branch I think it
was very very useful Jessie just pencil
these things out and
go on build the intents well you'll
probably find it as you've been setting
these things out as well you'll find
some branches that don't make sense
and you'll fix them up so with that some
final thoughts James yes so hopefully
you guys have got a good feel about how
you can use dialog flow within existing
applications also within existing
infrastructure and depending on the
company that you're coming from and I
think I'll loop this back to the
beginning which is what seeded this
initial idea which we actually haven't
fully fleshed out yet but for us
because we have so much data and we are
a large bank and we service a lot of
different clients we think that one of
our unique benefits is that we have we
can bring the right type of data to the
client when they need it and so for me I
was thinking about ok what happens if
both an internal user comes to a trader
who's very busy in that they're managing
that their portfolio and that user wants
to say to the trade you know why did the
exchange rate of this asset just spike
you know over the last 15 minutes now
what caused that now we have all of the
trade information that happened up to
that point we have all the economic
event data up to that point we have all
the market data up to that point it's
not beyond the realms possibility and
we've been building this so that you can
programmatically produce a natural
language response to that query that
draws on all of this data and frames it
in such a way that is human readable and
it's nice to read right so we can say
you know we're seeing a lot of leveraged
investors buying because you know the
economic release that just happened was
weaker than we thought and you know
we're now at the 94th percentile rank
for the month for this exchange rate and
so we're seeing a lot of you know
momentum in that direction you could
produce that report programmatically
through the data that we have and you
could imagine a user asking for that
just quickly on a chat being like why
did this happen you could respond in
chat in kind and so for me where I want
to take this project is more down these
lines
I think dialogue flow is great for FAQ
it's great for just the simple things
and for sure we'll be looking at that as
well but I think there's a lot more
interesting subtle things that you can
do which create the sort of overall
ecosystem of of text and of course there
are some client you just want everything
over API and that's fine too but for the
people that are in between this is a
great way to service many many more
clients with high quality content so
we've covered a lot of ground hopefully
you've got a good feel for it
that's it from me and just to say there
are some more sessions that are
available running tomorrow
and again thank you very much for
spending some time with us this morning
[Music]